maybe we wait like a minute to for
people to arrive
get started
all right something about 21 people
watching now
should we start
what do you think
yeah we can go for it i think
sure so hello everybody welcome to like
the first talk um in the series of talks
for the robust speech event
um this first talk is by patrick von
platten he's
a machine learning engineer here at
huggingface and he's mainly working with
audio
models and he's also the co-organizer of
the robust speech challenge
he will give an introduction about like
the robust
speech challenge and tell you like what
it's about and how it's organized
um his talk will be around like 15 20
minutes and then we'll have a q a
session where we can answer your
questions
um you can
you can pose your questions in the chat
anytime and i'll summarize them at the
end and we'll see that
we can answer them all
so without further delay uh hand over to
patrick
i think you're muted patrick
okay so i think my internet just
went off okay great i think um i can go
ahead then
and
yeah welcome everybody i'm super excited
to start this robust speech challenge
um with all of you
and
in this talk i quickly want to give an
overview
of
the the week um
what we're going to do
and then also ask some some common
questions you guys might have
so um
yeah so the idea is really um that at
this challenge we tackle um kind of
speech recognition systems that will
work in
in robust and settings that means we
don't want to just evaluate the models
in the end on
red out audio data but really on real
world audio data
and
also try to boost um the acoustic models
with with language models
um and i think in the last speech
challenge or the last pre speech sprint
you see now okay great so um we'll start
with the timeline
of the um
challenge
cut out for a minute or two um maybe you
can repeat like the very last thing you
said
all right perfect thank you um yes so um
in the beginning i just want to share
the timeline of the challenge um so
everybody knows
what we're going to do and um when we're
going to do it
so um today you can see i'm at the red
circle today's thursday and the
challenge will officially start on
monday the 24th of january
um
we have already given access to the ovh
cloud gpus as of today so um
starting today until um the end of the
the speech reverse challenge um which
will be on the 7th
of february you can train your model by
training model that means training your
acoustic model and your language model
um starting on monday when the when the
challenge will officially start
we um will
be giving you full support um on discord
so as as a hiking phase and also
um two members from from the ovh cloud
team
then um on
wednesday probably next week we'll
release the real world audio data
for the development set
so you can start um evaluating model
on some reload audio
starting on wednesday already
and then at the end of the speech
recognition challenge which will be on
monday the 7th of february
we will release also a hidden test set
um so
the idea is really that um you're going
to get access to some some hidden data
only at the very end so we cannot over
consume the model on uh
on this set
um and then i think in three four days
we can evaluate all the models on this
test data
and we'll probably give the results on
thursday then the the 10th of february
great okay um
i think now the the most important part
is to guide you guys a bit through um
the
all right i'm just gonna stop sharing
this and
well now it's like my room
and i'm gonna share the most important
file of the
challenge
which is this one so
pretty much all your questions and they
should be answered in this week
which you can find in the transformers
github repo and transformers examples
research projects
and robust speech event
so um here we've
kind of condensed all the important
information in one readme
i would recommend that you start with
too long to read
too long didn't read section here
and then this section should link to all
the other important sections here
so um
normally you should find all the
information you need in this document
and to give you a short overview of
every section um
the event will only be done in in
pytorch it should use transformers and
data sets so one section here which
explains how to install those libraries
then we have one section about
the data and how you can pre-process
your data this section is very important
because it explains a bit what data you
can use
and also how you how you can pre-process
the data um
pre-processing is is very important
because
for um for example you want to remove
punctuation usually for your acoustic
model however you should not remove um
you know letters so that the model can
cheat
um so that this section explains a bit
how you can normalize your text
without um
like cheating
great um
then the next section is all about how
you can fine-tune the acoustic model um
by the acoustic model is the the
wave-to-back movement
and this section explains everything
step-by-step how you can find unit
and the section afterwards explain so
you can do this with the ovh cloud gpu
that's a nice spelling error here
actually
[Music]
and there's also very nice video that
bastion from ovh cloud team just put
online
and you can also see here you can set up
an account and how you do the training
so
this should also be very important
then the next section explains how you
can add a language model to your
acoustic model
and adding a language model is
very useful to avoid spelling errors and
also just a general tool to boost the
performance of your model
um
actually one second i'm just going to
turn the light on
it's a bit too dark here
all right
okay cool i think that's better
um
great
then
we will go over
the next section which is the evaluation
so
the evaluation um they're going to be
three data sets normally the real use
for evaluation
and the first one is the the test set of
common voice
the second one if if possible will be um
some
some real data that we're going to
release as i've shown before the
timeline on wednesday next week and the
last one will be the hidden test data
we're going to release after after the
sprint
um
and that's pretty much it yeah one very
important section is also
the communication problems so
you you're probably going to encounter a
lot of problems and
and that's very nice so we we want to
help you
to to tackle all of them so everything
which is related to to bugs to arrows um
please ask the question directly on on
github so either on data sets on the
github repo or director transformers
um and ideally what you can do then is
you you create an issue and then you
copy paste the link
into the discord channel and maybe ping
anton on me or someone else and then
we'll take a look
but the idea is really not to to kind of
dump the error messages directly on
discord because this way um all the
knowledge that we can build by by
answering these issues gets lost in the
long run so we try to
to collect everything on on transformers
directly
okay great that's that's it um and now
in the last step
what i also want to show is a bit how
you can use the the hub
so
we really recommend that you guys make
use of the flying face hub for the
challenge
and um
to begin with i
want to share a bit an example um so
when you read the
the github introduction that i've just
shown i'll mention this more he could
often because it was a bit like the
demonstration model that i've done for
sprint
and
usually when you follow the script the
trainer automatically pushes
the the checkpoint and also the training
results directly as a model on the hub
and so everything which is written here
was not written by me but i was written
automatically by the trainer so it's
very convenient for you
um and all you have to do
is actually when you when you use the
training
is you you add one flag which is called
push to hub
and push to hub allows you to directly
upload all the the checkpoints
and pretty much all the other files in
your github repo
to the hub that's very nice because then
you can see right away what error rate
you have here it's easy for other people
to see
you also can actually record already so
you can use your
model already here for the inference api
and record and try it out here
so um i could now compute here actually
the
the answer
or the transcription to the audio
and it's also very convenient
if you're used to tensorboard to to see
all your
your metrics right away here
um so i strongly recommend everybody to
to use um this this push to hub option
um
great okay
then
in the last step i'm gonna jump back to
some common questions
that for sure will pop up
during the event
and
okay great i think like one one common
question most people
have and simply already ask on discord
is uh what data can be used
and the idea is really to use all kinds
of data you can find
um
so i think in a as a start what you can
do is you
you can start by looking at the hug and
face hub so
i'm going to share this as well
real quick
um
[Music]
so what's very nice is we collected
already quite a lot of
data sets for audio so what you can do
is when you log in here you go on data
sets
and then you can just kind of filter it
here by
should be something with speech
processing and then you can see we
already have 32 datasets here so
feel free to combine any of them if they
have this with your language for example
well common voice i guess um the
chromebook 7 here is probably the the
most important data set for you
um but then also
there's the the multilingual libre
speech which has also a lot of data for
for certain languages so feel free to
combine any of those data sets if they
they suit you or your target language
um
[Music]
great okay then
i also
think yes people already asked what
models can be used for fine tuning
um you can use any model you want which
is you can also if you want you can also
train your model from scratch but i
strongly uh recommend to not do this
because it's usually much easier and
gives you much better performances to
fine-tune a pre-trained model
um
probably the most
relevant model here is the new xlsr
model from from facebook and um we have
it in in three flavors so we have a 300
million parameter version the one
billion per meter version and the two
billion per meter version
um in my personal experience the the 300
million kilometer version
works pretty well for almost all
languages
so um so all of these checkpoints have
been trained on a pre-trained 128
languages
um and they should work pretty much on
every language you want to find your net
on
um and the 300 million checkpoint is
quite easy to to fine tune the one
billion actually as well so i think you
should definitely try it out and
in the one billion checkpoint also fits
on the gpu given by ovh
and the 2 billion checkpoint might be
difficult to to fine tune
because it's not super stable anymore
i'm at this size of training and
it might also take quite a lot of time
and you have to use tricks like uh
can optimized optimized optimize like
like low memory optimizers and
i'm not even 100 sure this fits on the
on the wii 100 s but um feel free to try
it out so so in general um you can use
any model and we also evaluate every
model the same so
we don't really care whether you use a
small model or a big model we can look
at
the final evaluation
and um
[Music]
this um but this doesn't mean that um
you should should always use the biggest
model and the purpose of the the whole
event is that you kind of created or
that we help you create a model that um
is most useful for for you task
and not necessarily that you have to you
know win the competition i think the
competition is a very nice site
motivation but um if for your personal
project or for um your use case you know
a smaller model which is obviously
faster an inference makes more sense
then please use that
and and we'll we'll make sure that
it's gonna it works well
great um yeah then questions i think i
already answered this so everything
which is back related please ask
directly on transformers or data sets um
on github
the questions now which are a bit
related to your your special use case so
those are questions where you think um
the you know like the participants the
other participants might not necessarily
profit from the answer that much and
it's probably not a bug in the in one of
the libraries
then maybe go ahead and ask on the forum
so i added the link here
and
then we're going to answer the form
directly so here's really everything
which is related to you know either how
do you find your way to vague um or you
know this doesn't work if we're going to
make this work with this bug should be
as public as possible um so that
everybody profits from it and also after
the event
um all other questions i think can be
asked directly on discord so everything
which is related to the
to the event itself you know like your
your name
didn't pop up in the google sheet or um
or any anything regarding the
organization
or whatsoever and please ask in discord
you can also i mean also if you have
problems if something specific doesn't
work and you don't want to open an issue
and you're lazy i mean it's also all
right to to use it actually to do it on
discord but then i'm probably gonna
remind you to to please open issue on
the transformers
um but in general like we're really
happy about every every issue and every
bug we get and we will help you as much
as we can
um
great okay now um yeah one of the
biggest questions is also whether your
language the language that you want to
work in has real world audio data for um
depth and test
and um so antoine did an amazing job at
collecting some some very cool um kind
of real world audio
um however we don't have
we don't have real audio in every
language and we're probably not going to
be able to
to to find this so um
i mean for example languages like
esperanto which is not even real
language it's very hard you know to find
like real audio data so um there we just
might do the final evaluation directly
on um the common voice test data set and
and only on the common voice test data
set
um however
there are a lot of other languages where
we didn't find real audio data yet and
um after this talk i'm going to share an
excel sheet in the discord
and in case you guys you have any good
resources where you can find or like
extract data from
and we would love to to get them
and and then we can use them for the for
the dev and the the test set and the
idea is here that um we obviously want
to be very sensible to what data we can
use and the data is going to be private
it's going to be used only for
evaluation and it's going to be um
yeah it's going to be private so it's
not going to be public for everybody
um so we can also
like we're also going to verify whether
whether we're allowed to use the data so
um you don't have to be scared
any licensing um
we'll take care of that but um i kind of
want to
shoot out here to languages like tamil
um we didn't find any real data for
tamil yet um luganda is another huge
language of chromevoice where we sadly
couldn't find any
any real data so in case you have any
good
links to to data and with resources we'd
love to have them
um and right after the talk i'm going to
share on a google sheet where you can
add them
um
usually the best way to to find
audio plus transcription is youtube
quite often you find good data there um
otherwise um you just kind of have to
search in the in the in the language
actually itself and try to find some
websites where there's some reasonable
data that can be used
um
great um so that's from my side and now
i hope there's some questions and
and um
i'm ready to retrieve them
yeah so
there is there are two related questions
that we can maybe answer in one go
by francois who's asking what happens if
you upload a model multiple times and
emilio asks like how do models get
versioned on the hub can i push multiple
models with the same name i think those
two questions
are related maybe we can answer it in
one
yeah and there's a very good question so
um
i'm also going to share my screen here
again
to show this directly
um in short yeah we have with git
version control for for the models um
which is which is very nice actually
so
if you uploaded a new model again um
what happens here for example i think
i've uploaded motor models here so you
can see this is the repo
and um now when you go on to files and
versions you can see that there's a
history here and that's very similar to
your git history you know in a normal
git report
um and you can see here
great commit messages by my bot
um but you can see here that i've
uploaded
multiple models
um and this uh this is kind of a git
history
um
so for example what happens here already
is during the training
you upload checkpoints and you can click
on it and you can see that i've uploaded
all these files
the the model itself in this case is the
pytorch bin
um and this was uploaded i think here's
step 500 this was done automatically
actually in the trainer
and then i'm sorry now i jumped out of
the history
and then you can see um it's overwritten
by by every um
training
afterwards so you can see
a 7000
and here we we overwrite the
model um
it's not actually the real model that is
going to be put in the hub so what
happens here is that the model weights
they're hashed
the hash are compared when the hash
changes when you re-upload the model
then it's overwritten and then when you
download this this file it links to the
new weights which are identified by it
by this hash
um so it's in short it's all based on
git lfs and it works very similar to git
and you don't lose any
any model and if you upload a new one
you can always go back you can actually
specify the version when you when you
download the model
um
yeah
sorry i think was there was a second
related question no i think that
answered both so if you use the trainer
and push a model twice with the same
name it just creates a new commit
i think yeah exactly and you can also
afterwards um you can override it again
with your own commit
kind of like i
i did in the history also in the end so
those were the micro myths and then you
can also add like a new model so for
example in the second training
um
there's going to be then a new kind like
string of of update steps for the for
the trainer and i also strongly
recommend actually that you
for example if you work on the same
multiple languages i think you should
for every language you should have one
model repo so let's say i worked on
swedish here
um if i find out that there's some some
much better training data and i'm going
to retrain my model i should do it in
the same repository if i ever want to
work on a new language let's say like
swahili i'll open a new repo and push
there so usually every repo corresponds
to one language if you have an improved
model just upload it right away
in the same repo
there's another question i you showed
like tensorflow integration on the hub
and gigablaze asks like is there also an
integration with weights and pisces
yeah that's a very good question i am
actually huge fan of weights and biases
um
we i think we didn't we didn't manage or
we didn't um do it yet um i think this
may they might be even on the roadmap um
however the the trainer is connected to
weights and biases so
if you actually so if you just pip
install weights biases locally
and you start the training script
with the hanging face transformers
trainer
then um all the metrics that i've just
showed in in tensorboard they're also
uploaded to your website's account so
this is actually very smooth and
and i personally also use weights and
devices a lot because it's great
um
but we don't we don't uh show it here we
don't display it here
on the on the repo yet maybe maybe it's
gonna come
i'm not sure actually
there is another question from clever
clubber um
asking why would you use another
language the test set is in english
right
oh sorry no no so the maybe i wasn't
very clear there um
we so the whole competition is going to
be for every language
so if if you have the best model in one
language you kind of want that language
in a sense
and we have test sets for every language
so at least at least the common voice 7
data set i think has 74 languages and
then you find the test set for all of
these languages
so when i previously said for example
you shouldn't use the test data for for
training i meant the test data of the
language you choose to train your model
in
we don't have sadly yet
real-world audio data for every language
i think we have like 44 or something
like this at the moment and we're trying
to to get more
um maybe also too to edit right now is
um in case
you work with a language where
that is not uncommon voice m7 and that
also wouldn't have any real world audio
for
then um maybe you can just ping us on
discord and then we should see kind of
together how much percentage of your
data we should use as test data so if
you have a very huge data set for
language that certainly isn't it's not
common voice
maybe you can use just ten percent five
ten percent as your final test data and
never use it for any
hybrid tuning or training um if it's a
much smaller data set then we might use
maybe like something thirty
um but those should be edge cases so i
really hope that for most languages we
have at least convoys data
um
little p is asking uh what about
training on multiple languages for
example
training um on the same family of
languages at the same time
yeah there's also a very good question
um so first of all pre-training has been
done on um
i guess like simultaneously on 128
languages so for pre-training it makes a
lot of sense um and also from from
people that come from nlp there's one
thing which is amazing actually in
speech if you think about this is the
the input to the model when you
pre-train is always audio so the format
never changes you know um in comparison
nlp when you switch for example from
language like let's say like english to
something like um chinese
the whole vocabulary has to change which
also means that your whole like word
embedding layer probably has to change
which makes it much harder to pre-train
on motor languages which often results
in you know these these huge
um kind of word embedding matrices that
um
that a lot of models use or um or models
have to work directly on bytes in nlp
the nice thing in speech is for
pre-training for example that you can
you always work with audio so it doesn't
matter which language so pre-training
works like incredibly well um
on um on like like together on every
language
and simultaneously now the problem in
fine tuning is um in in this event we're
mostly going to find you and and these
monsters are called ctc models
and there um the problem is that you
haven't have an output layer which
corresponds to your vocabulary
um and more precisely corresponds to the
the characters in your vocabulary so
let's say in english you have the
alphabet so you have 26
um characters which means that the
output layer has kind of like 26
um you know like a logic vector has like
26 entries
and the problem now is if you if you
fine-tune the motor languages there
might be a problem um let's say maybe i
think catalan and spanish should work
actually pretty well and actually i
think it's a fun experience to try it
out
because i think they share more or less
the same
vocabulary there however if you do
things you know like again maybe like
chinese and english it's going to be
very difficult to fine-tune um
simultaneously because in the output
layer you know english needs just the
alphabet chinese you need much more like
science you you want to transcribe too
so um
maybe maybe in short for languages are
very very close like catalan in spanish
i think it's actually very fun
experiment to try it out and um
i'm not sure whether it's going to be
better or not um i guess for catalan
spanish you do have enough you know like
data for
two to find your model just in a single
language
for um other languages however which
might be much smaller like like low
resource languages
um so so smaller i mean in terms of data
um maybe it's a regular idea actually to
fine tune on both
languages simultaneously if the
vocabularies are too different
cool
um little p is also asking like um
from last year
um they're in contact with like other
people and
uh lupe is asking like if it's okay to
collaborate together on the project
oh yeah it's a great question as well um
actually i wanted to talk about this and
yeah thanks for asking so yeah um for
sure so we really
um like want you guys who to work
together and to help each other um for
example if you have a you know like a
group of friends and you all want to
work in the same language please share
everything and
you can also if you want you can just
like upload one model and and then this
can be the winning model and then um you
know you you're the winning team
um
the thing is just like um it's very like
it's very time consuming to organize
groups
so for this sprint we kind of said like
we're going to give out one um gpu
voucher per person um however if you you
know like you work together um if you
know each other
which is gonna give one gpu voucher to
one person of the group and then you can
share you know like access
um if you want so um
yeah please please work together if you
want to um
in general also like we should always
try to you know like share our findings
so let's say like you work in a language
you find maybe that there's some great
data set out there that like no one has
ever seen it would be very nice if you
share that
um we reached like the full time but
maybe we can go over time like a few
minutes and that's like answer like the
last two three questions that there are
what do you think
sure yeah i think i think we can also go
a bit over time if there's some some
good questions
so emilio is asking like uh which model
is going to be evaluated is it like the
last committed one on on the model repo
or another one how is like the the
evaluated model selected
yeah it's also a great question um so in
short what we're gonna do is um there's
also written in more details on the
readme i showed in the beginning
but i'll share this
right now actually as well so i'm gonna
put
my screen up here again
one second
so let's say um
you made a model um and so you have
multiple swedish models for example
under your account and
in this case you can just kind of like
add all of them to the evaluation and
the way you add them to the official
evaluation is just by giving them a tag
which is called you can see it here
maybe it's called robust speech event um
so the important thing is that your
model um when you upload it to the hub
has two tags one is the language which
is sv in my case
and this should also be automatically
done actually the language by the
trainer so normally you don't have to do
with this the other one is this tag and
this you have to add manually and this
is actually very easy to do so
um the tag can be added
right here
on the readme so you can see here
there's some yaml code
and there's one section which is called
text
and for example if you want to add a new
tag you can just add it right here so i
can you know
look for talk and just add this here now
um so i would also recommend you to do
this right away um on the website
and then you can see here if i
go back to the model card you can see
here now i've added this tag and you can
click on it model for tech and the
reason is now um that
to do like the reason to generate these
texts is um if you click on this tag you
will see all models which have attack
um and here you can actually see one
model which was added to the official
evaluation list of models and then all
models that are here are going to be
evaluated so here i should also be able
to see the language
um th perfect i see the language and i
also have the robust speech event text
so we can automatically evaluate this
this model um
so in short what i would do is um again
like as i said before if you work on one
language only um it's i think it makes
more sense you just you know like use
one repo and you can also use more to
replace it really depends on you if it's
easier for you to use more to repos you
know you do like swedish version ones
with version two feel free to do it just
make sure that you add this tag that
i've just shown um it's a robust speech
event and your language
so we can automatically
kind of extract all models
there is one question about
if you create your own private data set
um what happens if there's like an
overlap between like the hidden test set
yeah it's also a very good question um
wow very very good questions so yeah
that might happen um and then i guess
it's it's a bit like maybe our fault as
a collectors of the hidden test data um
yeah then that's maybe lucky for you
like your model should perform very well
then on the test data
um
so
yeah it might happen honestly like we
like it's is there not that many like
platforms to extract data from in for
audio so this might happen and then the
negative you're lucky um however as i
said before the the competition you know
um is a nice site um kind of motivation
for the event the the real kind like
reason of the event is that we try to
kind of work together to build useful um
models for everybody um that's also why
i said like i mean you can all use like
the you know the biggest models and
people that have maybe like eight gpus
available eight a100s they can train
much bigger models and they're probably
gonna have better performance um and
that's fine but in the end of the day
like really hope that like the model
that you fine-tuned and the knowledge
that you gained during the event
is very useful for you um
but then at the same time yes it's very
nice to kind of win this challenge and
like we try to make it as equal and as
fair as possible which is incredibly
hard obviously um and in this case we
can't do much if you use um
the data that might be in the test set
for your training then lucky for you i
guess and and
that's all we can do maybe regarding
data sets also one thing i quickly want
to
show you as well
so um
we even if you have private data for
example for the event and um you're not
sure whether you want to like use that
you can also upload data in in private
mode so
um i can show this cma real quick so i
made this um
or maybe like i'll show it here right
away so for example if you want to add a
data set which you know is has some
sensitive
data and you don't want to share with
everybody you can create also private
data set here so
sensitive
data in swedish
and uh you can create it here and then
you're the only one who can see that um
but you can use it you know as just like
every other data set so um
you can you can read me here um or you
can also actually directly kind of
upload
files you know um so here actually for
example i could now
upload some dummy data um which might be
sensitive and then you have all the data
directly here and
then you create like some model card and
you can use it you know super easily so
here i can just like this is two lines
in python it downloads your data in this
case it's just text data we can also
upload the audio data or whatever it
downloads your data set automatically
and you can you have all the advantages
of the data set library the important
thing is because it's a private data set
you should pass this flag which is
called use authentication token equals
to true
um but then you can use it and you can
also be assured that no one has access
to your data set as soon as you make a
private
if after this print you want to share it
with everybody
um you can also flip it here to a public
data set
and then everybody can see it and people
can like it
um
[Music]
yeah so maybe maybe there's also as a
small extension so i i strongly
recommend to use the data set i think
it's incredibly handy and useful library
for for datasets in general and if you
have some private personal data
um you can use it in private mode that's
fine you can also you know just use for
the sprint and delete it afterwards but
usually if you put it up in private mode
it's uh i mean like if you put up a
private mode it's it's secure and all
can see it and it's just your
your um data
um
yeah that was maybe a bit
more than the question but
i think they could be useful
yeah i think it also answered some other
question
um maybe to round out the the question
answering there's there are like two
questions related to post-processing
um
one person is asking is like uh
automated something like automated post
processing allowed and another person
asks how are can lm going to be
integrated after the fine tuning is that
covered by the scripts provided by
hanging face
i certainly repeat this i think i
mentioned it
went down again sorry sure so the first
question was can you not like your own
automated post processing to to your
model and the second question was
um how is canon can lm
be integrated after the fine tuning is
that covered by the scripts that hanging
face provides
cool yeah um
yeah sure so maybe yeah the post
processing first so
um
yeah like any processing that you want
which kind of like stays within the the
rules um which is also great zone
against the roots but um in in general
you can add any processing that you want
for example let's say you build an
automatic spelling corrector you know in
um like maybe like a nice you know nlp
model that you
put after your your speech recognition
system that corrects you know like some
inconsistencies in sentences and in the
end it gives you a better whatever rate
super super good work and um that counts
however if you build some kind of post
processing which um
cheats in a way you know like which
maybe makes use of the
the test data
um
then that that's not allowed to look at
it um it's also related to this is maybe
a bit
um like you should remove all kinds of
punctuation i think because normally
punctuation doesn't have an acoustic
sound um
so like we think it's totally fine to
remove punctuation and to normalize your
your target data and your output data
from the model
um however it is not allowed for example
now to let's say like in english you
know you want to replace like all vocals
with one vocal letter you say like all
vocals are going to be the same they're
all going to be an a
then it doesn't work anymore because
then your words lose their meaning then
things like you know like words like
hello would suddenly be like something
like
like hala like just like one like vocal
for both vocals and um that that would
be cheating and that doesn't work and
then like the model can lose its purpose
um so
yeah like in general post pressing feel
free to connect whatever you want and as
long as like you don't cheat in that
sense you make it too easy for the model
um more information is also
written on the readme right away
um and the same comes for pre-processing
by the way so if you want to do noise
filtering great you go ahead um and and
it's perfect just you have to be careful
to to not make it somehow too easy for
the model um also maybe like
again like one thing is um if if you
know language very well if you're a
native speaker um and you for example
you find out that a common voice has
some you know like letters
that um
that like don't exist anymore in in
modern languages and actually like one
to one the same as other letters um then
you yeah like feel free to like replace
them with collect letters and make it
easier for the model because there's
some like you know messy data um that's
great um but um
like you kind of have to make sure that
the the output of the speech recognition
system doesn't lose its meaning so that
it's it's still like it's functioning um
so i really recommend also like um for
this case to to ask maybe like a native
speaker and ideally you are actually
native speaking in the language you work
in
um cool the second question is actually
also a good question
is the kennel m um and i wrote actually
a blog post for that that um
i gonna show now as well so there's a
blog post that's also written in the
readme by the way but if you go on on
blog
on the hanging face hub you can find
here there's a boost wave to actually
with engram
um and by the engram it is canon lm
in transformers and it's a very in
detail blog post which should explain
exactly first of all how do you collect
or like how do you get the data
um to create your channel m and then
secondly how do you how do you create it
actually um so i think
like all the commands actually here so
here you can see
this is the command that um
you know like canal m built
um ngram model so this shows exactly how
you can do it and i actually recommend
to you you can do this directly in in
the collapse so there's a button here as
well
um and then
you you can run all the commands in a
call-up and you can actually like i
really recommend to just do this in the
caller because um you don't need a gpu
to create a catalan
um
and you can actually just change
i think it could be as easy as just kind
of changing the
the language that you want to work in so
here i work with swedish so if you want
to work for another language i think you
could actually just change that
and maybe some other things farther
below and it works out of the box for
for your language
um
cool yeah and then the last section also
explains if you have created the kernel
and how you can integrate this
with transformers but there's also very
nice talk um right after this one from
the the cancer guys which created the
pisces dcd code diary which explains
in detail how to
or how to work with the pi city cd code
library and how to integrate the camera
model
um
so that's great
to the next talk in 20 minutes
yeah
um maybe actually i wanted like there
was i think there was one
question here
i think i think someone said yeah we
should all we should all use the same
test data um i forgot oh yeah i think i
think uh clever clover said this so
i i really agree we should all use the
same
hold our test set for sure 100 um
and
that should also be the case like no one
should train you know their model on on
them the common voice test data and we
can also we might actually like verify
this so if you see that the model gets
incredible with error rate on the test
data but the training doesn't look very
good
then we can check you know like we can
run some like short um kind of scripts
to check whether the mod has been
trained on the common voice test data or
not um and this should not happen so you
should not use the converse tested
because this is held out
test data there should be no hyper
parameter tuning anything on the state
that should be
looked as as like a hidden test set um
so i 100 agree like there should be like
the test data shouldn't be used for
training um and the same thing with the
the real audit that we're going to
release this should not be used for for
training that's only for evaluation
um
yeah and like i think the question
before is just like in case during data
overlaps
we can't do much sadly um but yeah
cool
okay i think that's this is it pretty
much from the questions no lender or i
think so and i mean if we missed any
question then you can always ask it also
on discord and then we can answer it
here
exactly
we didn't answer your question
all right yeah thank you so much um i
think the talks are probably a bit more
interesting this is just
a short description of how the event
looks like and i think the other talks
they're going to be um super
in-depth and interesting actually so i
really recommend you attending those um
and then if you have any questions just
um feel free to to ask also in the
discord you know like um
general sprint channel and otherwise
yeah i'm super excited to
to see some
powerful speech ignition systems in a
lot of languages
great
cool
thanks a lot and in that case i closed
the broadcast
awesome all right bye-bye
bye everybody